hi I'm John Cohen with science and I'm
here with you long shoe from China and
Miriam Coleman from the Netherlands and
we're going to discuss h9h seven and
nine the outbreak that's occurring in
China of a bird flu virus that was first
reported to be in humans on March 31st
and it has infected over a hundred
people now in China and one case in
Taiwan and there's been a lot of
scientific research that has happened
very quickly by dr. Xu and dr. Coleman
and others and we're going to take your
questions so one of the questions that's
come in is could previous vaccinations
provide some sort of immunity maybe I
can say something there so I'm assuming
the question is about previous human
vaccinations and the answer there is
most likely no because they are directed
to different viruses with different
subtypes surface proteins so dumb dr.
sure there's a question from JK that
asks isn't it time to China with
guidance from the international
community started taking animal
husbandry practices in China seriously
if not for sake of the animals than for
us I think what the question is getting
at is should there be more surveillance
yeah because thing I just ate a noisy
that any of my life well serious so I
could not get a job you think of coin so
could you please repeat the device again
what they do for this question but the
question is about the about the way
animals are raised in China and I think
about surveillance of disease and
animals and could it be improved in
China yeah actually yes so for for the
for the surveillance animal and I know
the human improved a lot but I currently
for each day and night I think the
biggest charity that this this virus it
I mean cannot cause any i think this
equal to poultry and so that that should
give each energy right now so we we
couldn't talk you know and photo/j
surveillance mac OS x y1 @ during the
pre provision yes so that's one of the
big challenges is that it doesn't appear
to make bird sick but i wonder whether
anyone has intentionally tried to infect
different species of birds yet with the
virus and to see if higher doses or
different species might actually show
some signs of illness or reduced egg
production has that happened yet i yes
sir so I caught it with your discretion
actually could we do not know the
effective specious affected by visa I 7
my roz currently pharmacy from the
detection result from the porter said he
looks like mostly mostly from the
chicken and then followed by a teacher
natok proof so what it is I don't think
it's it's the truth I mean reduced JJJ
and the country for production or not
but it affect something that people do
not like to you know too chicken to eat
freedom to eat chicken because
because all the challenge I desolation
because we do not aware for example with
the huarache taste come on for the
poverty doesn't got all decrease that
also means a professional I poultry so I
think that that's a lot of charity so
one of the Booker's stallers has asked a
question that I think applies both to
dr. Copelan and to china in the
Netherlands there have been famous what
are called gain-of-function studies and
I know that dr. Coleman it wasn't your
laboratory but they received a lot of
attention around the world where
researchers have attempted to take a flu
virus and see if they can make it more
transmissible through the air in mammals
to try to better understand what the
actual genetics are of human-to-human
transmission ultimately and the question
is are there plans in China to do those
sorts of gains and gain of functions and
dr. Coleman I wonder whether you know
whether their plans in the Netherlands
to do the same sort of experiments yeah
because this is a thank-you equation but
I think rebasing people needed to know
using the animal model to know the virus
kind transmitted among animal father's
using the ferrets mode kicking kicking
or dark is a kind of item of model
models to treat us garden because I
preferred it a positive are involved
with the item of auto studies corrected
by the hello some groups including in
China such as a scientist in China and
also former US CDC and other
technologies now they are doing some
experiments to study the church music
transmission capacity as a genetic
incapacity ologies i 7 my roz using
different matter
o Allah dr. Coleman what do you think is
that are those likely to happen soon in
the Netherlands so the I think stimulus
studies that that doctor Xu described
just not necessarily gain a function but
just simply what do these viruses do in
the models that are available so the
ferret models the mice models the
poultry maybe even pigs and yes I'm
pretty sure such types of studies are
going on all spent in Evelyn's so dr.
Coleman the Netherlands had an outbreak
a decade ago of a similar virus h7n7
what do you think we can learn from that
outbreak that might apply here you you
had great success culling birds but they
also were very sick birds so can we
learn anything from it can we apply
anything so i think the the most learned
most is just how fast these viruses
eaten in poultry whoa we did a detailed
study and we use that experience in the
comparative paper that we did with dr.
shoes roof but what we learned was that
in when looking in detail at the
sequences of viruses throughout the
outbreak which took which lasted two and
a half months we saw that several
lineages evolved in poultry so one of
the virus was transmitting from one form
to the next we saw several lineages
evolve and with that also some lineages
that had mutations that you could assume
would infect what it how to invisible
these viruses were two people and and so
what we learn from that is that you
cannot at the start of Narvik say I have
the virus i have the sequence now I know
how this virus works you really have to
monitor very closely rather than is
going how it is spreading
it is evolving because with that
important scene changes in the risk to
people I think that's an important
observation and the second observation
was that we had set up for to the
regular type of testing for people for
flu which it was throat swabs but in
that case the virus was very often seen
in ice so conjunctiva and so we needed
to treat a sampling regime so we cannot
be sure that that the regular flu type
testing works for these viruses and that
needs to be looked at I think I think
that's an interesting point you make
that in your paper dr. Xu is there any
attempt to look for pink eye for
conjunctivitis in China right now as a
milder symptom that might indicate
people have h 7 and 9 for the fifth time
into voltage UK you have no fama from
our kiss you from the chris information
material of the cases so there is
serious i yes the hell were you I
smelled it may all the cases I do not
really have have you seen pink I have
you seen conjunctivitis in any cases
sorry have you seen conjunctivitis in
any cases in China any website astrology
watch is a water fight oh yeah in the
Netherlands they saw that most people
had conjunctivitis when they had h7n7
have you seen any conjunctivitis with
h7n9 okay know what you do not see a
dentist preventive as their and
electives Mecca extremely necessary and
yes I cohabiting men measurement the
most cases I think twice ever invite the
most cases presented pneumonia and the
respiratory
there's been a lot of questions about
why it's predominantly in older men any
any thoughts about that from either of
you did there's been there's gonna
discuss in about the cases being
predominantly older men any idea why
well we might lost dr. shoeman marion do
you have any ideas about that so no well
i think the information needs to come
from china there's one possible reason
that there is an exposure factor that we
do not yet know or understand so that
there's something that that
predominantly men and all the men do
that puts them at risk for getting this
infection if that is not the case and so
far the information coming out for of
china has not found anything like that
if that's not the case it's it's really
hard to tell what is clear that most of
the patients that have been described so
far and seem to have some type of
underlying illness already so it's not
the the general health condition that
that seems to be getting the severe
illness which which is similar to what
we know of seasonal flu virus is it
first one of the questions that came in
from maggie is what makes this more
virulent than the seasonal h1n1 i think
she means the pandemic h1n1 that has
become seasonal and and and do you think
it operates by a similar mechanism to
h5n1 or are they very different i truly
think it's too early to stay what that
inspires is more virulent and then
not the ones because we are because of
this very strange age profile so the
seeing mostly older relatively older
people with underlying illness sort of
sends the message there must be other
cases that are milder unless does not
really peculiar about this age group so
at that stage I think we really need to
wait before stating that i don't think
we can say this is necessarily more
virulent than the others so we're
speaking with dr. marion kauffman from
the Netherlands who has studied the new
h7n9 virus and was also very involved
with an earlier outbreak of a similar
virus in the Netherlands and dr. you
long tube from China who is heading who
heads their influenza Center in Beijing
and i'm looking through the questions
now people who are listening please do
submit your questions and we'll try to
address them there's a question about
whether people should be concerned about
traveling to China I'm not sure if we've
lost dr. Xu or if he's still on dr. Xu
can you hear me well what what do you
think dr. Coleman would you be would you
be concerned how about traveling to
China no I don't think so okay great
what do you say doctors you should
people be concerned about traveling to
China yes before I also your this
question I just as your comment Vidya
today I see when I wireless come he'll
there without fire now we're at this
stage so based on the current data they
as I think a devious data but they
didn't hear data show that age 7 and now
iris I can in fact human easier denied
five Iowa but before they currently the
majority of the cases number detected
right now and and is taking a swim
so the very similar with with a
chihuahua so and also some very
preliminary structure that this virus
can replicate in the upper respiratory
and also the North respeto tracked by
the replication efficiency is higher
with a more rigorous Bella Terry tract
compared with the Apple a respected fact
the second doctor she I want to bring
people up to speed i think that's very
interesting doctors choose pointing out
is that he thinks that h7n9 is more
easily transmitted and if you look at
the total cases of h5n1 which has been
around since 1997 sporadically it there
aren't more than I i think what are we
at a little over 600 cases and we
already have more than a hundred with
the h7n9 in China and what he's
explaining is that where the virus
actually replicates can lead to how
easily it infects or is transmitted as
well so go ahead i'm sorry i just want
to bring people in yeah so that means
you know although this the h7n9 cases
asked for decreases butter if you
compare the cases number with the
pitchers number without further and work
is his number so for example during the
massive change it almost 10 years we
were only have 14 file fo our own cases
and in detecting in China are the during
another two months we have over 100 x 7n
cases detected for the last two months
so you yes oh this case is sporadic and
if you compare the number you can see
you do not stack as well as kenya fact
human easier I'm inventor Nashville Alma
and two people be concerned about going
to China shut sorry should people be
worried about visiting China okay
to your question how was China so I
think it currently travel to China is a
safe because we identified it that they
do potoo market is there is the risk of
faculty terrific center so currently in
Shanghai and other provinces we shut it
down of the new photo market so you can
see from from the case reported from
Shanghai after we shut down with clothes
they do put your market and so the unity
master with no new cases reported a
former shanghai city so that it
indicated that it proved that shut down
the do quadro market is is a good you
say you say you take admission to a
fearful for for the control of our
future of the break and so I think it's
5th out of China but do not i mean with
it any new porsche market so we by the
way we are shut it down a pony happy
yeah but doctor come and i have a
question for you given that you had such
success with calling should China shut
all of its wet poultry markets should
they just shut them down until this
stops is that viable I don't know I mean
that that's a that's a lot to do and to
ask but yes if you know that if if it's
very clear that that's the risk factor
then i think i'm sure china is looking
into how to control that and and
shutting down the markets in chennai
seem to have had an effect on the number
of new cases so that's an easy
relatively easy measure but the bigger
question is where does the virus come
from to those markets the people get
exposed on the markets but the to me is
somewhat puzzling that the surveys on
poultry farms have not yet identified
many positives so where are the chickens
that are on the markets
where they from where they getting the
virus from because that is more likely
at the root of the problem so it's I
think that's the question behind the
market question you know interestingly
with h7n7 you looked at the farm workers
the poultry farm workers and found the
bulk of your cases there we're not
seeing this huge outbreak in poultry
farm workers in China are we doctor Xu I
mean there's I don't know that you've
tested poultry farm workers in large
numbers as the Netherlands did but are
you seeing any evidence of people who
work with poultry having more antibodies
or more virus in the blood are you
seeing anything yeah yeah so I agree
with damaris as a quasi-religious you I
mean yes so a big stable we did it to
identify they read over of this virus in
which species in a way out so is where
you pretend yes I agree with that so for
the postal workers yes we have collected
a further loss solid material samples
former from torture workers including
the farmers of all day as the workers
who fail or slaughtered enemy religion
attentive to the to the party we did a
lot of finish all the tests yet but a
farmer did the results we have finished
the test with people not a fan I mean
anybody hold you and former from for
fermentation we called it their high
risk a professional approach it's
interesting to live with h5n1 and I
suspect with h7n7 the antibody tests are
very difficult to do these aren't simple
antibody tests I mean is it possible
that there are cases that are being
missed because people were infected a
few
months or even a year ago and their
antibody levels are very low and hard to
detect given the technology dr. Coleman
you you know this firsthand that it's
tough to do isn't it it's tough to do we
were actually sort of laughed at for
staying there was some type of
physiological reactivity initially
because we had to really tweak the
essays to measure something and what we
did see the only way we could
demonstrate it was real that it was
different between exposed and unexposed
people and that the low level antibody
reactivity that we found was found more
and people with conjunctivitis and less
in school who had received antivirals so
that told us that what we were measuring
was real but it was very low level and
it would not meet the standard sort of
the girls that are defined with a
seasonal influenza but I think in China
so the patients that are there of course
there now is the opportunity to see what
histological response is in those people
that will tell us whether or not these
tests will work for the sewer service
that's a very good point so what dr.
Copelan suggesting is that people who
are infected you can watch their
antibody response and then watch it
Wayne over time dr. Xu are you doing
that and are you beginning to understand
how to antibody response evolves in
people so for example you've known
people have been infected now for over a
month do you see what somebody looks
like in their antibody profile a month
after infection yes you already so we
collected their server I mean 20 samples
are far too pound serum samples for the
patients I would yeah and also Alberta
tea and take our the from us so that
were more than 10 young patients recover
the former I said that many fashion yes
we taste it it's a parecer
with the different measures so we at
this moment we think with regular
scientists using the cookie cookie blood
cell we can detect the antibody after
the ice over at night infection mutated
none stayed in the commercial face of
our fear of the patients so so the
tested method we used in currently but
detectives anybody in the portrait
workers and also yeah we discussed with
with exposure from the contacts so you
know why organization called contests
including expose 40 logical basis is
special for offenders in logica aces and
also disgusted with our legs was for my
other countries and also another way we
were current it and where I reason to
animal serums and sided the edema serum
against a seven-night then also we can
taste that Cindy tivity using
potentially security use a different
measure to see which were which messages
the best one to Detective anybody that's
very interesting so you're developing
more sensitive tests to detect the
antibody and animals as well yes so
Angie asks and this is a tough question
dr. Xu but why h7n9 h5n1 and SARS all
surface in China first why China okay so
yeah you're asked about it ask you mean
this question okay so I think I seven
night because i am not expert alba but i
can see something i bothered the
chitosan your friend I think but
partially because of it is special see
where mental situation
shanna and also the poetry project
cultural unity proto production season
so in sociology special ensalada a the
chicken back and the all rested in the
similarity and in some salsa regional
chana a whiteboard wintry and also mixed
with the poetry in families in some rest
pedals that enough so that's kind of
special special situation and also
special and rare mental and situation
included a class at the cultural
production system the special system I
think reason it is the possibility to
how we assault held between different
species is special for infantile virus
so for example serious alternate between
seeking portrait or we're both so I'm
here now with did not know what's a
virus original form but i wanted to
personnel i do that maybe the teaser
viruses kind of me so recently
assortment of deterring they take that
chicken and then white balls but we need
more and if they'd have to support this
is han dejado they took so oh Henry
Neiman who follows suit flew very
closely has asked with the
gain-of-function studies there were
three changes that were common in three
different labs that led to h5 and one
transmission in mammals and h7n9 already
has these three changes you have any
comments about that and how likely this
virus is to become transmissible from
human to human which which I should
emphasize there's no strong evidence
that that's happened as of yet
but given that those three genetic
changes appear to be in this virus is it
more likely to become transmissible
between humans are per common do you
have any thoughts on that and well I
think what me to learn so far from flu
20 flu is that it's not so easy to
extrapolate findings with one flu virus
to the other one so the changes that
have been found for 85 and one worked
for h5n1 in terms of decrease increasing
the transmissibility that does not
necessarily mean it's exactly the same
picture for this virus that needs to be
really sorted out it's it's obvious just
because it worked there it doesn't mean
it's going to work here exactly we saw
that with for instance this is TB to
mutation it was not initially found in
the in the pandemic virus of 2009 and it
popped up and it did not seem to affect
the virus at all so it may be different
in different backgrounds different gene
compositions of viruses so that's
important to realize and obviously from
the contact studies that have been done
assuming that the serology works well it
does not seem to be transmissible at
this stage so well let's let's keep our
fingers crossed so Addison asks an
interesting question Addison asked could
it be spreading Vita rodents and you
know I'd wondered about bats I've
wondered about horses you know there are
other species we haven't been talking
about that could be reservoirs that then
lead to the infections in the birds and
we saw with SARS that people at first
thought civets in the marketplace and
indeed it turns out to be bats harboring
the corona virus what do both of you
think about other potential reservoirs
that may not be on the radar screen of
people i mean horses have had influenza
by
is you know for centuries and there are
plenty of horses in China bats are also
great reservoirs of influenza and
they're mammals what do you think I'm
rodents I think the most obvious
question would be on on pigs there has
been some preliminary data that there's
no no evidence for infection in pigs but
that's where I think the closest
scrutiny should be particularly given
that that's also a big industry in in
the same region that would be mine yeah
and in fact there was some speculation
in the beginning with the dead pigs in
the in the river in Shanghai that they
were responsible for the outbreak
although no evidence supported that the
doctor Xu what do you think about other
hosts and reservoirs yeah we could
another huge crew could not exclude the
possibility you have a host so we needed
to do a highest so winners and the
educated ology us condition for for
other a house the other species to gotta
based on the current data you could look
back I mean predominant cheating he is
it that a firm was seeking so so some
experts are also in China they did talk
about to talk about the wider ponds and
him talked about as a host but we do not
have a date high yet we do not have a
live event so we need evidence to answer
your question so by the defense so
before I before I also wanted to say
something about say a human to human
transmission opposed as well so I think
a similar issues we did to think about
the human-to-human transmission first
based on our current knowledge we did it
to monitor and the mutations with a GD
to you for your time at the moment
millennia
establishing beautician and the DHEA DNA
and also he have a ecologist so is this
is a very important evil very important
each of area code of us monitors the
weather see you know [ __ ] and every
second I think it's a very important
files to do to educate me ology
epidemiology and so winners so for you
can pamper currently we do the closer
contact for more info and to the tooth
booty serology and also the virus virus
connections it across the contacts or
with symptoms and also to Suraj with
with or without the symptoms very
important for us to look at the other
clothes content and also a mother is
another issue we need to closely monitor
is a classical for the time of the
family clusters so each possible we
needed to do very detailed investigation
how many family clusters have you seen
no sorry I judged you how many family
clusters I read three how many family
clusters are there total right now yeah
so you can usually do from from hahaha
just published paper yeah I see family
class does but and I think it the class
was he mexican kitchen is very important
so we did it and also a lot that you so
we need to think about and basically our
all are currently i mean for example the
new friend also when a system so we
needed to to taste the edge semi and
nowhere else in this weather system
especially in the fluences in the
injured providers with the case
detective region so enhancement is a
kind of the winners for the pamper we
increases the same pony numbers in the
interested in vases and in our hospitals
in the time progresses reported
ticket I mean reported cases so that so
we did it to use different them whatever
in conclusion I want Amanda I emphasize
that we needed to use different I mean
mention different a system to close
monitoring the surveillance and also to
service I mean circulating in poetry or
the other house many other species is
also very very important so we did
realize this is the other animals in
portrait the other suspicious so in
family I wanted to say that we cannot
depend now one measure we needed to do
to too many things to cost money to the
worst mutation and your ownership or so
Maggie asked do you think the mortality
estimate of twenty percent or so is an
over estimate and or is it an
underestimate do either of you have
thoughts about that I mean it's very
hard to know how many people have had a
symptomatic cases or subclinical mild
cases like conjunctivitis what do you
what do you each think about that dr.
shoe do you have any thoughts about that
okay so yes Timothy pal Decatur yes you
and also a symptomatic case is also ever
recorded but and so forth that's a def I
mention what you did to use to do the
you Highness events in different even
the mechanism so for example in China we
have a lashing away your friend
inaccurate so little system basically
sending our hospitals so that during the
last one month we require we require
obviously their hospitals to connect
with the respiratory specimens to do the
h7n9 taste for all the hopeful for the
samples of the Connecticut but I based
on the current
ani sorry i did a magic about it but it
only three of four cases get a potential
this to see you find any other so in
suisun so I cause i think at this moment
the mail the case this yellow review you
will compare with the ammonia cases to
Syria pages but you know what one of the
one of the thoughts I I had is that with
your contact tracing you were relying
mainly on symptoms and you weren't
looking at antibodies in those people as
I understood it so you were looking at
more than a thousand people to see if
they develop symptoms because they were
in close contact with people but if you
were not looking at antibodies how would
you know if they had been exposed and
infected for the time and possibly
cleared the virus see what you would
know for this crust for this close
contact with all the symptoms we're
connected hi of the serum so once it
will connect your the u.s. deviation
time and another cell will be connected
out in two to three weeks so using this
measure we think of evil evil people and
also also we motive for the other close
contacts a health situation for 10 days
so using this kind of an investigation
protocol they think you for some mail
the case or I think I symptomatic cases
a habit further but the co for the
contacts within the week with 50 packets
are so dense the strategy we used dr. to
open i interrupting you you were going
to say so i was going to add this this
this is a mixture of two questions here
because if there's no transmissibility
from person to person then the contact
studies are not going to tell you
anything about my old or so food yeah so
the god
studies that that are informative there
is what is going on with the people that
are exposed to the same source and of
course that was difficult if you do not
exactly know the source but that's where
you will need to look so let's say
hundred people exposed to a known source
and then see what types of symptoms they
have the current surveillance and that's
not just in China but in many countries
will capture the tip of the pyramid so
the more severe patients that could go
see a doctor that go see treatment
because they are severely ill and people
just with a sniffing cup may not just
show up so it's not easy at this stage
to rule out mild cases I think so we're
about to wind it on there's a question
about migratory birds and how concerned
should we be about migratory birds and
what can you do about migratory birds we
certainly don't want people going out
there and you know saying oh these have
been found in Brambling let's get rid of
all the Brambling what what should
people do how should they think about
migratory birds the well of course we
know that migratory birds may spread
these viruses is certainly if they they
are part of the ecology if that's shown
for this one iris I guess this is all
about the way poultry or the farming is
done fancying off so that wild birds
cannot intermingle and their droppings
cannot intermingle with what's going on
in poultry and ducks that's a control
measure that that could work well the
China needs to change its practices and
I know that that's a risk factor so so
yes the biosecurity on farms is a risk
factor doctor doctor Xu do you think
China needs to improve biosecurity on
farms
persecuting you fast I have another
hexapoda and agriculture and so but but
the unit is the microscope medical
reports so I also the wider points here
also he hollers at my response to think
about now very important into such a
civilian see what it does for fresh so
at melrose some projects some projects
under green for for the surveillance in
the weather was right now I have no
tonight I might over yet the bad thing
if we win it with him with you for that
soil data i posle think from our from
the the sequence from the sequence we
can I do that the weapons may contribute
the TT 2 g's traditional talkin to this
no result and virus so but we didn't
know and tittle rest of the words came
in fact what those are not so as a
machinist some approaches and ugly so
for the father of security sorry I had
to know much about that so yes I think a
budding in general for simple I think it
is very important for the farms
forefront of culture father's johanna to
have a good about security I think
that's very provocative idea well I want
to thank both dr. Xu and dr. Coleman for
spending this time with us exploring it
I suspect we're going to be returning to
this sooner rather than later and thank
you all for joining in as well bye bye
yeah
you